what's the most uh sharp this is
important
[Music]
it's a small little uh mid-sized case
everything should fit snugly in there
get that out of here
[Music]
hello welcome to a trash taste speed run
pc build stream we don't know who's
going to go first with building the pc
trash tastes good discover trash tastes
good but in the meantime while joey
shakes that thoroughly we should thank
the providers of this stream thank you
gigabyte aorus for providing us with
3080s and 3090s which how do you even
get those they make them i'm pretty sure
they don't even have them so thank you
for getting them
so we're going to be building those
today and joey do you want to do the
honors and find out who's going first
today okay
i hope joey goes first because joey
doesn't know how to build you know
joey's never built a concealer
a week ago joey didn't know that this
was a motherboard
so he thought this was a cpu so even
though it says motherboard
motherboard right there all right here
we go first person is
gone okay all right it's early morning
with that literally i literally haven't
woken up yet yes i'm gonna be building
first
brilliant are you guys ready let me do a
connor right now
[Music]
is the motherboard now i'm guessing for
[ __ ] like this is an empty box
off to a good start though oh [ __ ] i've
never installed this kind of cpu before
okay or if you haven't then i'm
certainly [ __ ] we have an intel cpu
and intel cpus have uh a little bit of
annoying uh mounting for the cooler
can you tell me
i'm gonna take time out of my speed run
to say this is very extra packaging
intel i got a set um guys mainly the
time will be here guys
i found a i found a problem i know
because i need to ground myself and
these are three prongs
uh yeah all right you need to ground
yourself
you'll be fine so the time will end when
uh that pc boots but it has to boot so
if they get like so as long as it
doesn't boot that timer is gonna keep on
taking
there's one part i don't wanna [ __ ] up
it's the cpu i really hope i'm
putting this in the right way just just
wing it where was the last time you
built a pc gun
like two years ago i think okay that's
kind of long ago i can kind of remember
because i remember watching the linus
tech tips video as i'm sure everyone did
at one point
um building their first pc
where is the m2 supposed
what the [ __ ] what the [ __ ] all right
god is getting stuck
at finding where the drive goes i don't
want to unscrew
i'm i'm studying how do i unscrew i
think we're on a good start
okay is this do i have to like
it's on top i think you've got to turn
off talk how the [ __ ] do i turn it off
installing the cpu and that's fine
there's like a couple steps to it and
then immediately it says installing the
cpu cooler
yeah did he do that no he didn't
know all right okay
how do i untalk this i think he went
straight to the dual channel memory
configuration you did
yeah yeah okay okay
how do you how do pc go go broom
how do how do
okay i'm going to tell you this now
because you will get stuck on it for
hours if i don't tell you
um if you put it up no no no don't put
it on the thumb yet if you put it on you
won't be able to get it off
and also you don't need like the bottom
thermal thing and it like the screw
isn't big enough right to have both
thermal layers because the top thing has
a thermal layer i i have a more pressing
issue
which is this m2 does not fit
in this notch oh
who will win paul that is happening
right now uh
unsurprisingly that makes sense 82
is for connor uh and garth and i are at
nine percent
how do you feel about that car uh i
don't know i mean i'm going first
so yeah exactly it's a little unfair
right now to
to be doing it this quickly i have to
screw this in first before i scroll down
to you have to screw that in i should
tell you
[Music]
i'm going first and i'm still like
panicking because
it's been so long since i've built a pc
that i don't remember
each and every step so what do you start
the m2 right now
yes i am
[Music]
i mean like on the last pc i built the
my mc didn't even have a heatsink so god
imagine having an engineering degree
makes things make this so much easier ah
what are you doing i'm [ __ ] up did
you mean by plastic you mean this
you gotta peel that off okay
all right i finished the ram and mt
drive
all right let's do the split on the ram
and him
sorry i'm just on that case getting the
case out
oh that's a happy case you got that dog
that is a nice case little everything
should fit snugly in there
i know i'm gonna meet joey because he's
gonna spend half an hour just peeling
off the plastic
yeah i am i'm going to i can't believe
you you didn't even savor the peelies
i'm actually obsessed with just just
wait until it's joey's build
and you're going to see him like orgasm
peeling off plastic
i am going slowly i'm going to do peely
asmr on that [ __ ] dude
how are you doing gone how are you
feeling so far uh not great i'm not
going at the pace i wish i was
uh also this is like a really really
tight fit yeah so the
the iso iro shield is gonna be a pain
well it's
better to put that fat up first oh
yeah the [ __ ] let me have to unscrew it
god's realized it's probably better to
take the fan out so he has more space
you could probably do it but without
taking the fan out but
it's probably going to be really nice
very tight it wasn't this tight
when uh so 62 of the viewers watching
have not built pc before okay that's
good i'm glad i'm glad i'm not the only
one
now for the time i've been dreading
because the only thing i've never done
before
is install a water cooler um so i don't
know
how to install the water cooler i like
the water that just sounds like a
disaster waiting to happen but it's
like it looks [ __ ] amazing it's so
aesthetic
it does like the concept of having water
near some of the most
expensive electronics it's kind of
stained in a loop as long as you're not
going in your pc bear grylls tearing
stuff apart with them like a knife
you'll be fine it just goes on top and
that's it it's a brick
um am i reading this right do i have to
install a back plate
on the motherboard which i just
installed
uh wait wait no
perhaps there's another way you can
figure it out my thinking is
maybe you don't need a backboard maybe
you do
i'm not sure yet i think you definitely
need a backboard
if i need a backboard definitely do for
intel this backboard does not want to
come off
that is not the way you do it oh my god
that was the sound that like old
apartments made during an earthquake
yeah that was literally
uh japanese earthquake once i get the
water cooler done i'll be a lot more
confident
uh right now i'm kind of like swimming
without a float
and i'm lost at sea right now and i'm
kind of hoping i'm doing the right thing
but i don't know if i am is this meant
is this back brace meant to be wobbly
um oh god so this is probably the part
where you can easily [ __ ] up the most
i think how so which way do i put the
fans
[Music]
huh
i'm about to apply thermal paste and
that's the part where i just like i
don't want to [ __ ] up them so that's
supposed to be tight what [ __ ] screw
do i use it says use
g g for guards which i can't
[ __ ] i'm just gonna go by faith now
and i'm just going to hope it works out
right now this is this is where i pray
i've heard of this uh
thermal paste stuff okay um
is that there's this thing called
thermal paste um but i've also heard of
people stressing the [ __ ] out about
the place yes you gotta eat it before
you uh you start with a pcc right
you gotta like [ __ ]
[Music]
it was a pre-applied thermal paste and i
was like stressed out i wasn't thinking
i just grabbed the thermal cooler and i
grabbed the thermal paste and like
ruined it all
got is it in isn't it it is in
hey nice are we in oh it's tight
yes i think god has done it he's done it
oh my god okay just save the people wait
wait save the peeling when you when you
put the cooler in right that was
appealing
right you could save it all right he has
successfully got the cpu in
he needs to now get the uh fans
this is the second part that i've been
dreading
um that looks right can you see me
cradling this like a baby
i'm pretty sure this is the exact same
way you'd hold a child i think you'd
actually
hold a child more violently violently
i chose death today it's connor's first
unborn child
guys guys it doesn't it doesn't go up
top
it does it does not go up top does it
navi i have just figured this out
it does not
i know this doesn't go up top because
the power sock is right there
and the fan blocks the power sockets
therefore it does not go up top
but
i'm literally staring at our streaming
pc and it's at the top
yeah so that's that's nonsense god is
having a midlife crisis
i am okay so if you want to go to a
close-up
of what i was talking about having a
mid-life crisis
okay so let me explain to you um two
issues
one this fan seems to be very close to
this radiator
right here that just doesn't seem like a
good thing uh
number two it's blocking it's blocking
this power socket why would it be a bad
thing if it's close to the radiator
just wondering number two the fan is
blocking this
uh power socket um
so yeah i don't know paul live is
chatting i'm actually very confused now
because
i assume that that's going to need to be
plugged in and
the fan is working it so somehow
there is a way you can do this can you
we're not going to we don't want to
spoil it can i take a wild guess
sure you can just throw things out uh
you know what i got i was waiting for
like the god tier gasps yeah
uh i don't know like plug in the power
socket first there's not enough space
is that all right there's not enough
strength it's not his face he's the
setting is that not it oh you said this
on the face there's no
space so it's has been walk us through
your process
so i can't i can't install this fan
and have whatever power sockets are
powered so i'm going to try and see if i
could put the power socket
connectors in first and then
almost as if chat was spamming that gun
that's what i said
i made a good guess holy [ __ ] this is a
tight fit
but it fits
it just about fits let me write that
down
write that down right there write that
down this is god's master class of how
to build a pc
just go through like the five stages of
grief and panic at the same time
[ __ ] everything up worry that you've
done everything wrong when you've done
it right just worry
if you've done it right anyway okay
install fan
correctly i'm about to unbox the 3090
uh since very few people have this now
i'm sure this is going to be the first
time a lot of chat has seen the 1390.
this can be the first time i've seen the
30 90 so let's let's get a close-up of
this
okay check this oh oh look at that
oh my god jesus christ
yeah that's a big boy oh lord she coming
the chumps yeah you man handle that
so 92 percent says that psu before this
game
okay noted thank you chad i'll write
that down uh the wire
power supply which the power supply is
already in so
that i i put the power supply before
power supply it might be a little
difficult to do all the wiring now
yeah so uh i might have to unscrew the
power supply maybe
oh look at that wiring it's like a csi
crime scene in that case look at that
oh god [ __ ] cool jesus christ
sorry what did you hear what did you hit
i just hit my
knee against the table i hope we got
that 4k okay [ __ ] i
just need to unscrew this god what's
happening um so you remember how i
plugged in
some of the power sockets before i
plugged in the radiator so now
i have to plug these into the power
supply and i don't know what the optimal
route to plug these
in this is a yikes way of doing it
unfortunately
um you may even have to unscrew the
radio to go
um i think i plugged the wrong thing in
this
this is the palace this is the cpu power
supply isn't it
no it's it's it's the cpu power supply
it's the same
what happened i'm gonna have to unscrew
the radiator
there it is i'm good
yeah i'm good i'm good i'm good talk
talk us through your process
i'm screwing the radiator that i screwed
out screw i'm
i'm screwing it in again um
[Music]
so it's restarting because he [ __ ]
everything the ramblings on madness
so what i'm doing is i didn't [ __ ] up i
did exactly the right thing i had the
right wires in
yeah um and then i psyched myself out
thought i had the wrong wires in
in fact i didn't have the one why didn't
i have the right wires in um and
now i am screwing back the radiator
which i didn't need to unscrew
uh did that make any sense that sentence
is 10 times longer than this
part of the split has the mental
breakdown the [ __ ] is this
the what the [ __ ] what are all these
okay
like i don't know what the [ __ ] this
gamer pc is but whenever i've installed
a cpu cooler it's only needed one wire
this has
three why does this have three wires per
fan
oh um you sound like
the minecraft as an electronic engineer
it looks like i'm creating a short
circuit right probably
but as a kid uh this arrow and this
arrow
points together and they connect in with
each other
there's also a wire here which i don't
know where to plug in that's a
stutter cable and i don't see a sata
input
at all so maybe i'll just leave it
unplugged i don't know i'll i'll get
back to that later i guess
i think i'm almost done uh famous last
words
oh oh look at it oh
jesus all right
i
oh [ __ ] okay okay is it gonna boot
anything
this is the first time i've built a pc
and it booted up first time
literally the first time it's ever
happened hog let's go holy [ __ ]
there's no energy on this fan okay that
works yeah everything looks like it's
working the cable management is
a war crime it's probably the worst
cable management i've ever seen of a pc
build but that's god's problem to fix
well it looks good it looks like i mean
it's functional here's the thing guys
i'm an engineer right i don't care too
much about build quality
ah all i really cared about is that it
worked
and this is why i was a systems engineer
i just needed to
make sure that the system worked and it
worked functional to the specifications
i was given
and the specifications i was given was
that it boosted up to the bios
therefore by my standards it is
a successful build and that's all that
really needs to be done for this pc the
lies we tell ourselves
to make us feel better all right i think
i'm ready people are saying like joey's
gonna take four hours five hours dude
i'm just gonna be happy
to get it done my bar of expectation is
very low
are you are you starting yeah [ __ ] it
let's do it all right so
in three two one go go
and joey started joey uh make sure you
don't start with the cpu
uh i got the motherboard that's the cpu
right jerry
that's the cpu exactly the cpu looks
like right that's the cpu so download
more ram
download the ram first
[Music]
this is good this could be the end of
joey's run right this could be it this
could be the right
this is the run this glitch is a hard
one to pull off right at the beginning
of the round
for a really difficult clip here yeah
you've got to make sure you line it up
in the right spot yeah you're
you're you're basically holding like
over a grand right
right which orientation it goes
[Music]
are you swaying right now i'm sweating
right now uh so you have two options
right now you can read
the manual or you can ask chat which is
what i did a lot yeah um and chat is
right on the ipad screen
so if you wanna ask chat
you did
[Music]
under its retention time is it supposed
to be this tight
yes yeah all the way down
i think you've done it has you done it
have i done it i think you've done it i
think i've done it
you won't know if you've killed the cpu
until you start the thing yeah
does is the cpu secure
i'm looting uh like if you like wiggle
around
you touch it touch the cpu
let's not talk about that you literally
just said make sure it's
wiggling around so i was like how am i
going to check if it's wiggling around
i obviously [ __ ] push it around it's
fine
okay so think joey you need to screw
you need to screw it in you should think
i'm going to tell you the answer
i think the answer is fine the answer is
think
okay um
yeah there is a screw for that and he
has to find the screw in the motherboard
box
wait it's inside the motherboard box
no that's not it
guys we're live can you talk
sorry joey this is a surprise but it's
just fun terrible entertainment
i don't know i don't know about youtube
but i feel like our commentary would
just ruin this moment yeah yeah let him
find out
[Music]
in the box yeah yeah all right joe what
are you looking for
well i don't know chad's telling me to
check the box
you think you got it i think that's good
everything's screwed in i think that's
good
so now the case oh [ __ ] sake
[Music]
i just came all right joey does this
every time he tries to spread around
like the [ __ ] apex virus to everyone
yeah i do yeah it's great the world's
most deadly virus yeah
so 10 deadly viruses
what the [ __ ] was that how's it going
joe walk us through what's going on just
secured the motherboard in hey
motherboard all right so that's
completely secure just under an hour
so now on a very good pace tell us your
thought process because joey is now
on the water cooler looks very
very daunting doesn't it because i know
that i have to use the thermal paste on
that and then it's like kind of stick it
on
and yeah secure it what is this like
black black plate
back plate that right is it this
is this the back plane what is this
okay the instruction manager is
installing the mounting bracket
but
got [ __ ] up here because he installed
the cooler on first
instead of the radiator so should i
attach the radiator first
it's up to you joey you can do it in any
order you like
just you tell me the [ __ ] right hand
on a scale of one to lego how fun is
this
one this is not fun at all no isn't it
not fun learning though
i mean it's fun learning but i've much i
think i would pref
there are more optimal learning
environments than this i think this is a
this is literally trial by fire this is
this is very much trial by fire
so the cpu gets very hot joey very very
hot
um and if it doesn't cool down it's
going to break
right uh and overheat if it hasn't
already i'm sure there's nothing
supposed to put
like a pea size like a imagine a pee
yeah
like a tiny amount not not much not much
just a little sliver kind of in the
middle
yeah yeah like a little bit not too much
okay
[Music]
jesus really tight on there
that looks pretty good to me so he's
gonna secure these screws in
make sure we get a nice tight fit and
that way that cpu isn't going anywhere
won't leave me like my wife did
[Music]
there's a lot of wires here yep
there it is uh don't know where to put
them
you can wrap them through them joey let
me give you the advice i'm the wiring
expert here
would you rather be doing joey building
this pc or playing apex
building this pc joey's just finding
different screws
to screw in and hoping to god that one
of them actually fits
i actually can't find the [ __ ] screws
all right do you need help joey i don't
can i like see which screws they want
all right let me
okay i'll i'll go help joe these boys
are figuring out
how to screw in the fan i normally when
i build my pcs
i normally like have a little bowls to
separate them separate which ones are
which you know way too [ __ ] tight
twist it out oh okay bro
just put it in hope for the best yeah
great advice
the salt is such great content
so sydney is going to come and
commentate with me this is the thing
that god does i don't know anyone else
who named pcs he told you like sydney
you have to name it yeah yeah
that's what he said yeah that's not a
normal baby you have to name it
it's like it's like naming a pokemon
right you have to yeah it's like
i don't think you're supposed to name
pcs i don't think that's a normal thing
do you not name your pc no no
it's just machine number one c dog pc i
think i call it
you built it it wouldn't exist without
you
it's not breathing it's it's it's
breathing to connor it has
fans not like you
[Music]
i guess i should just start putting in
the graphics card now
is everything plugged in where it needs
to go into you think well the thing is
i don't know what's supposed to plug
into where so what is joey doing right
now sydney can you see what he's doing
he's putting in the graphics card yeah
what what step is he doing before he can
put that in he's doing something
he's removing the nails
that are in the way putting it in nail
nails i don't know like i'm trying to
like untwist
that is not the definition of moral
support
hello chris
hey dude doing good joey's in the middle
of building a pc
wondering if you have any words of
encouragement
this is why chris is my boy this is
interesting so you're on twitch now
right i can see you on the screen
on the shoulder for me i want to feel
like i've got some sort of interaction
how does it take to build a [ __ ]
computer how long do you think it takes
to build normally chris
[ __ ] 15 minutes chris help me out
here like what am i supposed to do
help him out
thank you for joining us chris thanks
for the words of encouragement
bye chris all right see you later bye
how'd that feel joey that make you feel
better
yeah totally i just realized the cpu
fan port and the cis fan port
this is in the [ __ ] way yeah
are you gonna have to unscrew it
i'm pretty sure i said okay i'll make
sure not to do that
if i remember correctly got [ __ ] up
here because he installed the core on
first
instead of the radiator so should i
attach the radiator first
i am gonna have to remember my goddamn
hardest to not do that now otherwise
that that will be true monkey brain so
right now joey
is screwing his radius back in
how many more things you have to plug in
after this joey i
would tell you if i had any idea
because apparently half of these wires
don't [ __ ] do anything
oh yeah a lot of them don't so i
genuinely don't know what i need to plug
in or not
what time are you aiming for corner
hours sub two hours
but let's just uh we'll see if joey's
computer boots up
all right starting out let's see if it
boots oh wait
will it boo is the tv on
oh yeah you got to turn tv on oh oh wait
oh
oh oh oh bios bios ready time
that's time
i am never doing that again
never in my life will i be doing that
again
that was the worst experience
cleaner than yours much cleaner than
yours i need to pull
these wires out a little more yeah yeah
but it look it works
joey how'd you feel when a [ __ ] on a
beer joey
so now that you've done the pc build
yeah would you have preferred to play
apex for three hours
don't build a pc
just so apex over pc building no pc over
anything what
no cheers joe you deserve it that's not
that's not very kick w of you joey
three two one
oh beautiful let's go
delicious start with the cpu is joey
yeah i know how i know what to do now
now now you know where the parts are now
i know all the parts so this is easy
mode for connor
you know
i mean you even saw the cpu intel cpu
before right
there we go smoothly all right
so far so far so good
what is going on i thought this is going
to be a smooth ride
it doesn't feel is it was it this tough
can you come here
you're asking for help already no no i'm
just wondering it's just because i don't
want you to break the [ __ ] seat
it was it was pretty tight when i put it
down yeah is it this time but it's lined
up though
what's going on here i i would
commentate something right now but like
the inside of my brain is like steampunk
where it's just like cogs and steam
i just think it's when nothing is
working
we'll be fine yeah we'll be fine
guys it's not the wrong slot we have we
have four ramps yeah people like think
it's joel's
channel yeah yeah it's for ramstein so
he's got it right
that click never gets old that click is
so nice like we we've we've set
everything up
possible to make connor succeed so it's
only
oh yeah okay yeah my success is your
success right
that's how speed running works right
dude my computer was working fine when
my monitor was connected directly into
my motherboard
so like why am i even loading these like
steps
what else what are you going to use your
brand's new gaming pc for
joey the the with the exclusive 3090
that uh is in very short stock right now
i don't know
render out a video i'm not even going to
upload it i'm just going to render it
out for fun
i'm just going to render it out for fun
yeah this doesn't fit
i don't know what's happening here well
i'm trying to get the standoff back in
but it doesn't fit
and none of the ones in the box are big
enough to go in this hole so i don't
really know what to do have you tried
every screw
the sound off here but i can't get the
standoff back in now because this is
attached to the thermal
so it won't go back in unless i put it
back through but even then i don't think
it
joey do you do you want to help
[Applause]
there's like one screw that comes with
it yeah so i've got
three screws here and they're all the
same size and they're the only ones that
are single screws
yeah that's it that's that's the one i'm
pretty sure we'll try it again but i
don't think it's gonna work
having fun there laughing at me yeah
[ __ ] you
trash taste versus screws who would win
i would like to say that connor also
does have an engineering degree
uh like me yeah i'm the only one without
him in here
he had the least problem with screws
apparently yeah so you should have one
long screw and one short screw
yeah yeah and then the [ __ ] and then to
actually screw down the end or two there
should be a silver
like it's small yeah i've got three here
and none of them fit
oh they should can you actually show me
something i'm gonna be here all day at
this point
i actually don't know joey's the
experience computer
seriously i think can help connor well
in
in here yeah literally put that in it
doesn't go really yeah watch this
yeah it should be like that welcome to
the world where joey helps connor build
a pc i have to push it down
we've seen it we've seen it all chat
we've seen it push that down oh yeah i
did have the same problem it should be
the longer one
the longest so that one but then what
goes in here i know i know they did
like so you're basically having the same
problem as i did
and what i did was i think i just found
it
from a different font
it's literally the short screws that you
have there the three short screws that
you stand off
is here how did you take that off which
i mean it comes off because there's
nothing screwing it down why did you
take it off
well no it comes off because if you when
you take out the screws yeah oh i never
thought i never took mine off
well no no no i i wasn't trying to but
you can
oh no i know you can't you know
there should have been something that
prevents you from taking this off right
there
uh so these screws fit in here how's
yeah i put mine in like like fine yeah i
don't know how we [ __ ] this up the
adhesives were the part that [ __ ] me
up
i like how connor used the word we here
well because none of us know what's
happening
i i [ __ ] it up but no one knows what
happens it's communism
okay okay i [ __ ] this up but also
no
i guess connor just has to screw down
his m2
using the heatsink so the m2 itself is
not going to be secured to the
motherboard but the heatsink is going to
be secured to the motherboard i mean i
think it's still going to work
i just screwed something else and i
guess i'll just use that
but you just screwed in something else
yeah what does that mean
i just screwed in another piece that i
found screwed what piece when i just
took it out originally i just screwed
that in i don't know if that's fair
though i don't know if that's right
hopefully connor doesn't need that screw
later i don't think you will
i hope he doesn't you'll just do it [ __ ]
it we'll do it this way i'm sure it'll
work you want to see the problem i'm
having now
what i actually can't get this off like
this
this is now i can't get this one connor
you [ __ ] us so
much how you [ __ ] it so
much like what have you i joined
he literally forced the screw in you're
on a serious red split right now but
the run's not dead you can come right
the run's not dead just
just do a couple of gold splits and
you'll be good bro i'm going to sandwich
this bit
all right that's the memory donald trump
all right it's on to the case now all
i'm saying is joey
is that we didn't need a lot of help
until we got to the [ __ ]
[Music]
[ __ ] right get that out of here
garbage i've never seen someone so
offended in my
life as a joke is when someone peels off
something fast
i don't even like enjoying it embrace
you in a monkey maybe pull it in
there you go there you go yeah it's
really [ __ ] tight
sweating just trying to pull that [ __ ]
oh my god come on what are you trying to
figure out now
no i'm just trying to figure anything
out so what he's doing is he's learned
from our mistakes and he is
gonna at this rate at this point in the
run gonna start plugging stuff into the
motherboard
oh nice and then pulling it all into the
back yeah
yeah would have saved me a lot of hassle
as well i gotta figure out
a way to get some time back in this run
honestly
gotta find a miracle we need a christmas
miracle right about now so connor
tell us your thought process right now
what are you doing right now what are
you doing for some reason
i can't get the cpu power in i don't
really know why
the cpu pattern yeah i'm trying to get
these in but for some reason it's
it doesn't fit i don't really know the
shape of the
ports the same because there's a lot of
like single
port ones where the shape is like kind
of different so this is all the same
what the [ __ ] am i teaching i don't know
i don't know i don't know i don't know
what the [ __ ] i want
i actually don't know what i'm talking
about why am i giving him advice
the last time connor read this many
words he was probably in college
what are you doing now connor uh well
i've plugged all the stuff from the
motherboard in
and the cpu's in and uh
but everything can be plugged in right
now it's plugged in all right so now i'm
just going to go back to do the other
part
you're doing the fans right now yeah i'm
going to believe you're not
like on path for 15 15 minutes connor
what are you saying chris chris is gonna
have some words for you yeah yeah
[ __ ] i disappointed chris at his
legendary 15 minute pc build linus is
crying
these [ __ ] cables are so goddamn
annoying did you have to use one of
these with the
rgb of the fans what are you talking
about uh the fans
uh to get all these wires connected up
wait what
use what so come on come on so i i was
explaining to connor
how the right way to connect the stuff
basically saving him a bunch of time
because i'll explain to him that what
[ __ ] me over was realizing that
this is
yeah this one can't go anywhere yeah why
the [ __ ] would they do that
what's wrong with that what the [ __ ] no
it's because
in case you need to connect to another
fan often so you didn't catch any of
these cpu fans no
what oh [ __ ] i plugged in the
cpu thing the wrong way no wait did i
no i didn't know i think so you got it
man guys i don't think connor's like
gonna make this up in two hours yeah we
lost the sub two hours boys i let you
down on that
it's okay though you can still get the
dog man i'm still gonna get us the dab
guys yeah all right here we go graphics
card
oh finally the chunky boy chunky boy is
about to come in
and you can do the split here we go guys
we're at the ghost
final stretch final stretch we are
currently at 212
so connor has roughly 15 minutes to
finish
i reckon it's gonna be [ __ ] close
it's either he's just gonna make it or
he's just not
okay all this depends on if it boots up
correctly the first time yeah that's if
it boots up correctly
if it doesn't if it doesn't then we're
gonna keep going
yeah i mean i think i think you'll boot
up the first time i think
i think he can continue the stream so
far the
gpu ps and the wiring split are both
gold you literally clipped through
you literally he clipped through the
wire he clipped through he did a wire
clip
he just admired my cable manager
here we go it's the moment of truth okay
go
go three two one
oh there's a light there's there's a
light no what's going on
hold on that same thing
same thing happened to me press press
the power button again
wait wait can you flick the power on
maybe wait is the cpu in
oh no oh no
not the first time well going on 15
minutes you got this man you got it you
got it
here we go it's gonna it's gonna come
all right
here we go all right red light's on red
light
sign and go
no what's not working
oh no connor oh
connor you [ __ ] jigsaw now oh my god
oh god we were two for two
how could you connor why did you break
the street
you were the chosen one press the red
button on the motherboard
no don't press the red button on the
bottom
oh wait the call is not turning on
though
oh oh wait wait wait wait wait wait wait
it's about to be time is it about to be
time it should it should appear this is
a plugin chat
oh here we go
oh
that's a trash taste record you beat
god's time by
10 minutes 10 minutes the cable
management is clean as far as that is
clean
cable management what are you talking
about shut the [ __ ] up
now it definitely looks the most clean
out of all three of us
definitely make it cleaner though but
we'll do that for sure hey man you did
it
did it we did it we did it guys
guys we we won we won we won guys
we won
it was our failures it was our success
to be fair connor your success was built
on
our failures
were my mistakes built on your face tell
me where i'm wrong connor he stood on
the shoulders of giants
it was my mistake
how was your build stream experience
horrible i mean like realistically like
i probably won't do it again for a while
but at least now i can say i've built a
[ __ ] pc so at least now you can say
you've built a pc
that can run apex yeah um that can run
the game that i
can theoretically run apex yeah thank
you very much to
gigabyte orris for sponsoring us big
shout out to you giving us
these lovely lovely gaming thank you so
much thank you so much for the 30 90 uh
i don't know
when i would have got one without the
stream i don't think i ever would have
got one absolute [ __ ] legends and uh
thank you to you guys for
tuning in to the entire stream thank you
to ashley yeah i didn't forget it this
time we'll give you a whole piece
we will reward you a whole pizza a whole
piece
you don't deserve it actually sorry okay
all right there's one more challenger
left and that's chris yeah that's
correct
oh my
chris's 15-minute beat pc build thank
you so much for watching
uh if you enjoyed this please let us
know what other challenges we could
maybe do in the office we'd love to hear
what you yeah we have a lot more space
to work with we have so
we have more room yeah we there was no
way we could do this
stream in the old office no way because
we would have been cramped around this
table
and we'll see you guys and hopefully uh
a much nicer looking
yeah afterwards i guess the next time
you'll see our faces is this this
weekend
oh yeah sure the episode which is normal
it's really yeah yeah all right
all right cue the trust for the national
anthem oh
check this out
[Music]
foreign